très vite hors alice michel fiszbin en
direct sur ce plateau michel fize
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
alors on l'a vu une manifestation contre
le chômage contre la précarité nous le
rappelle le dernier volet les dernières
mesures de cette réforme sont entrées en
vigueur mercredi
pourquoi le gouvernement est resté sourd
à toutes leurs revendications parce
qu'on les serve cette loi a fait
beaucoup
je crois qu'aujourd'hui d'abord les
choses sont claires il y à bien de
france il ya une france d'en bas qui
comprend non seulement les catégories
populaires mais la majeure partie de ce
qu'on appelle les classes moyennes et
puis j'allais dire une petite france un
microcosme médiatico politique qui au
moment où nous commentons ces images est
en train de débattre et souvent
d'ailleurs des débats forts stérile sur
des sujets qui sont très loin des
préoccupations immédiates des français
je pense à l'immigration à la question
des fonctions régaliennes de l'état
voilà est donc dans notre france qui
souffre cette france d'en bas eh bien on
retrouve évidemment toutes catégories de
population il faut rappeler d'abord que
c'est aujourd'hui une france qui est
extrêmement majoritaire
1 la vraie france c'est la france qui
souffre alors c'est la france qui se
lève à 4 heures du matin au plus tôt
pour aller travailler c'est la france de
la vie chère et même de la vie très
chère comme on l'a vu récemment encore
en guadeloupe et en martinique eux c'est
la france d'un personnel soignant qui
était épuisée et qui est mal payé deux
de surcroît c'est la france des
retraités dans les pensions sont mangés
par l'inflation c'est la france des
travailleurs précaires dont on parle
encore aujourd'hui toujours menacé par
quelques plans de licenciements c'est la
france des étudiants qui sont comme
abonnés aujourd'hui aux restaurants du
coeur assez la france des femmes seules
1 qui elles aussi ont du mal à finir les
fins de mois c'est la france des
agriculteurs des paysans des chauffeurs
routiers regretté voix des petits
patrons pour y rajouter même des
chauffeurs de taxi et j'en croise
souvent
en blanc sur ce plateau bien voilà dès
qu'ils n'arrivent plus à s'en sortir qui
ne compte plus les heures et puis qui se
retrouve finalement dans des situations
de survie voilà et puis n'oublions pas
nos immigrés 1 qui nettoie nos rues qui
nettoie nos bureaux et qui nous rendent
la vie la vie agréable voit la seule
fille ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire que
l'élite qui nous gouvernent ne peut pas
comprendre finalement les mots qui
traverse cette société comme l'a
qualifié d' en bas je crois que c'est
une c'est une administration qui ne
comprend pas l'importance du social
voilà dans le social évidemment dans les
grandes catégories que l'on dit qu'une
habituellement politique économique
internationale
le social c'est toujours la cinquième
roue du carrosse voilà c'est ce qui
vient après quand on a examiné tout le
reste voilà eh bien il faudrait
peut-être considéré que le social doit
se considérer avec un grand s est que le
social dans une démocratie c'est quelque
chose qui est prioritaire d'ailleurs la
maire d'ivry sur seine on l'a entendu
tout à l'heure qui étaient présentes à
cette manifestation a déploré le manque
d'élus de gauche à ce rassemblement
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors ça
c'est un vrai problème parce
qu'aujourd'hui savait ce qu'on appelle
les prophéties autoréalisatrices donc à
force de vous dire que le pays est à
droite ont fini de par penser
qu'effectivement il est à droite voilà
mais moi je pense que ce que l'on voit
dans ces rues manifeste bien le fait
qu'il ya aussi encore une france de
gauche voilà et qui a besoin peut-être
de retrouver un petit peu de couleurs et
d d'être là où les conflits sociaux les
les bagarres 1 au quotidien sont sont
aujourd'hui multiplier a donc c'est un
vrai problème que l'effacement de ses de
ses élus et notamment des élus de gauche
michel fils vont rester avec vous on va
parler d'une autre manifestation en
cours à paris elle aussi on en parlait
de cette crise sanitaire qui a creusé
les inégalités là aussi met en lumière
les problèmes de l'hôpital public en
france manque de matériel de personnel
il ya eu le ségur de la santé a pas
suffisant selon les soignants ils sont
donc de nouveau dans la rue à ce samedi
nadège abderrazak et notre reporter les
surprises sont largeur a tout de suite
bonjour anna des z'arts comment se passe
actuellement cette manifestation
[Musique]
écoutez amira cette manifestation du
personnel soignant touche à sa fin alors
des délégations syndicales ont pu être
reçus au sein du ministère de la santé
le ministère qui ne bouge pas d'un iota
et qui ne veut rien entendre au sujet
des revendications à du personnel
soignant le personnel soignant qui eux
réclament l'arrêt de la suppression des
lits qui leur demandent plus de moyens
en quelque sorte pour sauver l'hôpital
public qu'ils estiment être en danger
qui plus est en cette période de crise
sanitaire je vous propose à ce sujet
d'écouter quelques manifestants que l'on
a pu interroger en début de cortège
dans cette situation où on nous impose
un pass sanitaires eh bien on supprime
les lie donc là il y en a cinq mille 700
camps ont encore été supprimées on en
annonce d'autres et c'est parfaitement
incohérent avec la situation que nous
vivons on est dans un monde de procédure
on en train de 4 c'est le métier
soignants alors les plans blancs existe
on enlève de plus en plus des soignants
et ça fait des années que ça dure
bientôt il y aura peut-être plus de
maniche aura plus que des chômeurs
soignants peut-être ou libéraux c'est
parce qu'on veut l'hôpital public doit
avoir des moyens est actuellement les
moyens du ségur sont insuffisants
nettement ils ont essayé de rattraper le
coup mais ça suffit pas ils le savent
très bien en tout cas le gouvernement le
sait très bien donc je demande à olivier
ferrand et à d'autres comme tous mes
collègues qui sont là d'arrêter de nous
mettre la pression procédurale de
l'europe pour faire des métiers puis
exercé des métiers de bureaucrates un
cortège qui a réuni beaucoup de
soignants quelques milliers mais pas
seulement il y avait aussi des
enseignants des étudiants venus d'un peu
partout en france de mayenne de maine et
loire de vendée ou encore de rené puis
il y avait des élus politiques des
députés notamment venus de mayenne
écouter
puis de plein fouet la désertification
médicale parce que nos soignants sont
épuisés parce que dans ma ville à laval
les urgences ont fermé le soir à 18h30
c'est à dire que l'après 18h30 les
patients aient été orientés vers
d'autres hôpitaux d'autres départements
vous pensez bien que c'est une perte de
chance vous pensez bien que ça n'est pas
acceptable aujourd'hui cette présence
elle est légitime tout simplement parce
que nous portons la voix de notre
territoire la voix d'un territoire qui
veut un égal accès pour tous à l égal
accès aux soins pour tous nous voulons
préserver nos hôpitaux parce que nos
hôpitaux sont aussi un symbole important
de l'attractivité de nos territoires et
nos hôpitaux sont menacés donc nous
sommes là pour les défendre et je vous
le disais un ces entrevues entre à les
délégations syndicales au sein du
ministère de la santé n'ont abouti à
rien les organisations syndicales qui
préviennent puisqu'elles n'ont pas été
entendus par olivier ferrand leur
ministre de tutelle la prochaine fois qu
ils déambuleront dans les rues et
manifesteront il ya ce sera devant
l'elysée pour interpeller emmanuel
macron le chef de l'état
merci à 1 à des jeux pour toutes ces
précisions michel fize on vient de
l'avoir un ads cette manifestation de
soignants ans tendu en ce personnel
hospitalier finalement ce qu'ils
demandent c'est plus de considération on
les écoute plus alors il ya d'abord
évidemment une revendication d'être
mieux entendu mais surtout je crois que
ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est que la
crise sanitaire c'est en réalité la
crise de l'hôpital public et au delà la
crise d'un système de santé qui a été
probablement l'un des plus performants
au monde qui reste peut-être qui risque
peut-être de le rester mais avec des
moyens des moyens supplémentaires je
crois que il ya la fois un besoin de
considération c'est vrai je le disais
tout à l'heure en scène un personnel qui
est toujours mal payés qui est dans
l'épuisement avec des conditions de
travail qui se sont dégradées avec la
montée de la crise de la crise sanitaire
tout ça est connue est connue depuis
très longtemps donc finalement quand on
fait le bilan pas nous avons 5 6
millions de chômeurs nous avons
peut-être 10 millions de pauvres
n'oublions pas probablement au moins 300
milles sans abri des femmes seules comme
je disais tout à l'heure qui sont sains
qui sont en perdition
ça dresse un tableau assez sombre de la
situation et je rappelle quand même
qu'une démocratie et sociales ou n'est
pas le propre de la démocratie c'est le
partage et en particulier le partage des
richesses le partage des ressources
voilà et c'est la tension encore une
fois au grand problème du moment je
pense que le grand problème du moment ce
n'est pas l'immigration le grand
problème du moment
c'est l'hôpital public c'est la santé
des entreprises voilà et c'est la
protection des travailleurs qui font
vivre ces entreprises justement
l'hôpital public qui lie à ses sept
fermetures de lits à peu près 20% je
sais que mon entrain de raconter parce
qu'il ya un peu petite bagarre au niveau
des chiffres en tout cas certitude
alliés ont fermé dans le très nombreux
les hôpitaux faute de personnel mais
pourquoi parce que la profession ne
semblent plus attirer michel fize alors
comment on stimule justement
l'attractivité de la profession de la
profession en des soignants savez un bon
on a beaucoup sorti le carnet de chèques
1 ces derniers mois je crois qu'il faut
continuer et pour la la bonne cause il
est évident que les personnels soignants
sont très mal rémunérés
sont épuisés je le disais d'ailleurs
j'ai peut-être préciser quelque chose
que l'on ne sait pas c'est que
aujourd'hui il y a environ 50 médecins
qui 7 qui se suicident par an voilà donc
ils viennent s'ajouter aux longs
cortèges déjà des suicides est connue
articulteurs policiers également qu'ils
sont en en tête en tête de liste des
personnes suicidaires donc je pense
qu'il faut revaloriser
considérablement le métier de soignant
comme il faut revaloriser on l'a dit
aussi le métier d'enseignant qui par
rapport à nos voisins européens est très
très mal récompensée par rapport à un
métier qui est de plus en plus difficile
l'art manifestation contre le passage
d'un ter manifestation dg des jaunes des
soignants contre la précarité le chômage
on a eu cette méga d'à peu près deux
mois l'hiver 2020 ça fait beaucoup pour
manuela prendre justement c'est ça le
jeu de la démocratie
je pense que je pense que le président
est aujourd'hui il face à deux défis
évitez absolument 1re confinement
sanitaire qui serait peut-être lourdes
conséquences pour son projet
présidentiel est évidemment éviter une
grave crise sociale qui couve depuis
quand même plusieurs mois 1 on a une
france et gilet jaune des blouses
blanches mais il ya ce qu'on n'a pas vu
mais qui aurait pu être là 1 la france
des robes noires les avocats aussi un
qui pour beaucoup sont dans des
situations de grande précarité de grande
précarité dans la rue ya quelques temps
et qui étaient dans la rue il ya
quelques temps voilà on aurait pu
rajouter encore une fois toute une série
de médiers qui ne sont pas là
aujourd'hui mais qui seront peut-être là
le week-end prochain alors c'est un
constat malheureux on a fait depuis le
début de cette crise en est riche elles
s'enrichissent et les pauvres
s'appauvrissent oui je pense que à côté
de cette france majoritaire qui est donc
une france qui souffre il y a une petite
france mais malheureusement grands par
la richesse car on l'a vu 1 les plus
riches se sont enrichis
avec la crise sanitaire et même parfois
ce qui est plus redoutable grâce à la
crise sanitaire donc il y à celles et
ceux qui ont fait des profits sur le dos
évidemment des pauvres gens qui sont
dans la rue aujourd'hui pour réclamer
tout simplement des moyens de vivre de
vivre décemment savez les les gens sont
pas aussi matérialiste qu'on le dit
voilà ils veulent avoir une vie décente
pouvoir nourrir leurs enfants leurs
traces et un minimum un minimum d'avenir
à tout ça tout ça c'est important alors
derrière il ya évidemment l'espoir à les
gens avancent ils ont de l'espoir sinon
c'est le désespoir la dépression et la
colère quelquefois donc la colère est
toujours une une possibilité
démocratique
michel fize merci d'avoir été avec nous
sur ce plateau et puis je vous dis à
samedi prochain la main sur du prochain
merci